[Music]
we're in Lebanon for a while now
the country has witnessed unprecedented
anti-government protests they've cut to
class religions gender and region
[Music]
protesters say they are tired of the way
their country is being run
they Satan has led to corruption lack of
services and little prospects further
fixes and the protesters have already
gotten results after two weeks of
demonstrations the Prime Minister
resigned and a new government was formed
but many want more that slogan demanding
that all politicians go has become
emblematic of this movement
[Applause]
so what are Lebanese protesters up
against when they say they want to
change their country's system it all has
to do with the political rule book
written over half a century ago
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Siraj it's a coiling this whole
revolution has been like a calling we're
all willing and leaving our houses and
families and jobs to actually unite on
the street towards a certain objective
were certain that you live alone so
having such a collective conscience
being risen at this point makes me feel
happy and strong and hopeful I'm tired
Perla Joe has been protesting since day
one for her this is personal then the
way in my family this is part of the why
I remember the year I stopped between my
school and university because I couldn't
because it's so expensive this is part
of the why I remember electricity being
off and me not being capable of turning
on the heater when I was in my family's
house this is part of the way
Perla blames career politicians for
Lebanon's problems some have dominated
governments for decades
some of them has been there ever since I
was born
92 27 years speaking with the name of
the people while generations are rising
within different thinking within
different consciousness within different
education I'm still in the system that
has proved itself to fail let's dive
into that system and how it works or at
least it's supposed to Lebanon's
political system is all about religion
there are 18 officially recognized
religious sects laws required that most
of them share power in government
Parliament seats are divided among most
of these sects with each given a
specific number citizens can only vote
for candidates from specific sects
running in their districts this quota
based system has deep roots in Lebanon's
history it was enshrined following
independence in 1943 and reinforced
following the country's bloody civil war
the original goal of the system was that
of inclusion the idea was that there are
so many sects in Lebanon and very
different numbers that everybody gets a
voice is that way nobody's marginalized
this means that there's almost like an
engineering of who's represented this
structure has made it difficult for
anyone outside the mainstream parties to
participate in politics to understand
just how difficult that is
I meet loudly hi Diane
in 2018 she and others tried running for
Parliament on a secular platform with no
connection to establish sectarian
parties it was important for us to speak
in the name of the people all the
citizens regardless of their sex or
their community yes we were running
through a sectarian very sectarian law
but the spirit that we had but being
born Armenian Orthodox Laurie was forced
to compete with others of that sect in
her district in Beirut it's a Christian
stronghold still living with scars from
Lebanon's 15-year long civil war against
the invader that invader citizen from
the other community over a fellow
citizen from the other neighborhoods
would just like a different sex night
neighborhood Laurie did not win a seat
in parliament her experience raises
questions about whether sectarianism in
Lebanon accomplishes its aims some fear
a system that was aimed at inclusion is
actually dividing people you can
definitely tell that this system has
created some sort of confusion about
what it really means to be Lebanese what
that identity looks like it's you know
where does allegiance come to first is
your own sack does your own community in
particular or is it the greater Lebanese
state or the state as a whole so how is
this all related to the protest movement
dr. Ian ISM of course impacts everyday
life especially the functioning of a
state because it gets in the way of
things
in many cases for example we see the
mainstream political parties of Lebanon
in the absence of a functioning Civic
state that provides health care and
education and so on they become the
go-to for its support they become an
alternative Social Security that's
something that many protesters including
Perla whom we met earlier say they have
dealt with my mother was I couldn't get
into a hospital without the certain vote
because they own a hospital like we have
no insurance the government doesn't
provide you with what you need they got
the support in exchange for votes so
it's almost a transaction so what's
wrong with politicians taking care of
their constituents critics say this kind
of patronage creates an unsustainable
situation for the country and it's seen
as a key reason why hundreds of
thousands have taken to the streets
demanding a change of system today a lot
of people use the phrase unum Azua
and no the United us with hunger Unitas
was poverty even they realized that
those at the top who are making the
decisions have led us to this crisis so
let's ask someone at the top what do
they think about what is going on in the
country to understand I sit down with a
loud he's a leading member of the
largest group in Parliament the free
patriotic movement and nephew of
Lebanese president Michel on when they
generalize the accusation they are doing
wrong they don't have the right to say
everyone is bad so when they say condone
Jannik you know you don't agree with it
of course I don't agree why there are
almost people who do politics we're not
all corrupted just saying we don't talk
to anyone we don't engage in dialogue
with with the government or with any
political parties etc and then we don't
then we want to take them all out this
is not realistic unless you can do a
coup d'etat well do it if you can't no
we have to live with it do you think
that Lebanon still needs sectarian
politics it needs of course you know
these are diversify societies and you
need a minimum of safeguards to ensure
everyone that they are being able to
to get the rights cannot move from a
sectarian government in command system
to a secular one from a day to another
that's a process
I support the process maybe there are
people who are already they're more
mature on this level than others in the
society but you still have lots of
sectarian groups and sectarian people
then you have to move them forward in
their way of thinking and their
education and every Lebanese people are
not educated enough to make a choice for
a secular state I didn't say that I said
you have to include this secular
dimension and their education also this
protest movement has included a lot of
young people who perhaps are less able
to understand these arguments that you
do you tell them they are leading this
change they are ahead of us I agree they
are ahead of us in this in this run and
in this in this past to change Lebanon's
minds and to move it to a secure system
these people are leaving of us
while it is hard to tell when this
change might translate into politics
many young people I have spoken to say a
lot has already been gained at the end
of my time in Lebanon I sit down with
five young activists from different
political movements to get their take
people actually reporting and from the
second day of the reading they were
tearing apart the pictures of the
leaders and we were trying to
communicate with people from other
communities from other regions in order
to collaborate or to coordinate for
protest as it same time so it kind of
broke down that wall of fear from the
other other than breaking the the fear
barrier other than breaking sectarianism
barriers people are speaking are
speaking out about everything related to
corruption scandals of just flowing
right now and journalists are feeling
empowered to be taking part of this the
most like fascinating game from me is
that the street itself became the most
powerful political artists right like
this is this amazing manifestation of
like democracy in the big sense
succeeded in pressuring the system and
showing the weakness of the leaders
leaders especially about most of these
people thought that these leaders were
like strong and unbeatable and they were
they were here forever and they would
stay forever no it showed that the
traditional governance mechanisms that
they were using is they were crumbling
from within and hence it presents a huge
opportunity now to break away from the
system this is also a game
it's not a revolution yet you know
because you need to see the results
today there was something that changed
yes but have we seen actual and concrete
results left no I don't think that we
have seen something that goes on the
long term because the political class is
still the same the same deputies and
same political leaders are still naming
the ministers who are going to be
participating and the government they
are still looking for their share of the
game I think it's an uprising it's not a
revolution because I don't see the
pollutions as something that happens
within a very specific time frame or
that something that is a very incident
phenomenon
I see revolution as a continuous process
that takes a long time it's not about
what we call it but most of the people
are calling it a revolution they enjoy
using the term revolution let's stick to
it if it's more emotional to people if
it's keeping the if using the word
revolution is keeping the momentum let's
call it a revolution if uprising just
keep it keeping the momentum let's stick
to uprising
[Music]
you
[Music]